Gary your book that you have on
Kickstarter right now campaign the
writers guide to Hollywood was it your
idea or did a colleague suggests it - no
it was my idea really evolved
organically because before I was
producing films I was managing Dell I
was a literary manager writers writer
directors directors and I was new so I
had to not only watch their careers but
I had to watch my own and I didn't even
consciously become aware until much
later that I narrowed it down and carved
out very specific strategies long
structure and then I collaborated with
young writers all the years I was
producing most of those films are
written by first-timers over the years
people come and say how do you get break
in how do you get access how do you what
do I do
everyone's lit there's a pathway for
everybody except creative people right
if you want to become a financial
planner or almost anything there's a
pathway you get this school and you take
an exam and you get a certificate and
you join the mothership and you go right
that doesn't exist for creatives so I
realized that I started counseling
people and then I started teaching
teleseminars which I didn't like because
you can only get the information out to
some dozens of people at a time you
couldn't reach a big group and there are
a lot of people who want this
information so I thought out of
self-interest and out of trying to help
more people I would just discipline
myself and finally I said definitely the
book of these strategies not telling you
so it sounds like you had already begun
the structure of the book a long time
ago because you'd sort of hone
is about what it takes is that true or
did you sit down and night and just it
all poured out it was hardly one night
wish now these it's the book is a
distillation of all the practices that I
use as a manager and as a producer
because it's really about and and then I
started writing and it took me about it
it took me almost a year to write the
first rough draft of the manuscript and
to figure out how to order it and make
it really simple so that people could
actually pick it up read it and say I
got what's in that chapter and I know
tomorrow how to put it into practice
what's the one takeaway if we tell us
right now I'm sure there's many things
but one of the sort of a teaser tips
that you could give that's in the book
there are so many I would say to begin
with my mantra is relationships trunk
results and often times you see
especially screenwriters they have been
taught wrong I believe they've been
taught to send out query letters that
are kind of standard letters impersonal
letters to people they've never had a
rapport with in hopes that someone's
going to request their script read it
discover them and say yes and while in
the eighties that might have worked a
bit better it doesn't work so well today
and most writers will you know say no
that's not been successful as a strategy
so one of the key things in my book is
how to make it fun how to gamify how to
be successful and really getting in
those doors through the telephone in a
way that doesn't put the onus on the
person on the other end of the phone
doesn't make them do too much for you
too soon
rapport building phase right there's the
rule of three you make three points of
contact I show you how to do it exactly
how to research incentive that it's
really simple it becomes fun it's like a
game and if you finally realize that
it's you're in control and you're equals
it gets a lot easier thinking of the
rule of three and the age of social
media puts someone tweet someone three
times would that be sort of a way or or
is that still sort of putting the onus
on it's it's it is a strategy and it can
work but you can't tweet three times and
then ask them on Twitter or on Facebook
or any social platform to enter into a
professional direct relationship it's
too public it's not appropriate you can
build some rapport there but then you
have to echo that you have to actually
pick up the phone call their office or
speak to their assistant introduce
yourself as a living breathing creature
with a name and a face so to speak and
make it mutual create a dialogue create
a you have to have a goodwill ambassador
on the other end of the phone and at
that point then yes you're the context
is set and going back to social media is
it alright to pay say hey look at my
project or my or is it better to engage
this sort of person of interest with
something of their own you know book
instead of having it be about yeah it's
I mean your goal is always self-interest
ultimately right or you wouldn't be
reaching out so the question is how do
you do it and at what point in there
were relationship building process
utility if you come to me or I come to
you and the very first thing I do is say
Carol you read my my book or my script
or whatever it might be you're an
extremely busy person as we don't learn
today that's a that's a real challenge
but if I come to you and I say I would
like you to be my friend first of all I
know your body of work I know who you
are I've researched you by the way you
went to the University of Virginia I'm
from Virginia and you find some common
ground and you make it fun you're
charming you use some humor you're
comfortable and your honors can you say
I'm not a priest writer but I so admire
your body of work right here at the
three reasons I chose to call it you
would you be willing to give me four and
a half minutes to be my homeless five
minute mentor I have one question that I
really would appreciate your response to
no one will say no because that's very
flattering it's honoring their wisdom
and it's very friendly the quantum of
work is over the second they finished
their answer the second time asked maybe
their advice to seek their counsel about
whatever it might be certain kinds of
projects in theory right or
what do you look for when you're looking
for an entertainment attorney to
represent a young writer what would be
the right questions for me to assess how
good they are whether it's good match
you can ask them make up any question
you want as long as it's relevant and
let them again that's a second time
right and you've already spoken to their
assistant a couple of times first you
always build that bridge first never
rush through the assistant you want to
honor them because they're overworked
doggedly tired they have a rough life
they're underpaid they're
underappreciated if you come to them and
show them respect first they're going to
what speak well of you to the boss and
the boss listens to the assistant think
always I do you you you've invested
there you pulled that person out of all
the competition to be your personal face
of you're honest the voice of your
audience
so I try and enroll that person the same
way a couple of conversations keep it
really short is this little time I come
back next Tuesday at one o'clock when
your boss is at lunch do you spend a
couple of minutes with them you research
them and get a couple of questions in
mind many of you calculate to the boss
and your patient because what you're
building our relationships not going for
the brass ring each time
so yeah when I get to you I ask you
questions and the rule of three for me
is the first time we're strangers to one
another the second time were slightly
familiar by the third time it's oh
that's Karen right now I can begin to
walk over that bridge but again ask
advice honor them make them your mentor
draw them when you ask a question our
brains are wired very predictably you
take a step toward you you need to come
up with the answer it's just where we
are that brings you closer to me because
I'm not asking it so when it does come
time I'd rather give you say you know
what I have a script that I've really
polished I believe and some feedback
that I've gotten you show that you're
professional I've gotten some field one
script analysts to produce writers and
you know my hand marry and they've all
said it really is well-structured the
characters are in engrossing whatever
you say
that said they're not you I would love
your home however I don't want to ask
you to take two hours of time with my
spent
I will send you the first 15 pages if I
haven't garnered grabbed your interest
by then all bets are off
right if I do then you'll ask me for the
balance is that fair and all I want is
some feedback that's a 5 minutes maximum
because it will take them what less than
10 minutes to read 15 pages of a
screenplay
and even spend a few minutes on the
phone with you so you're very mindful to
ask for very very small Quantum's of
work even after you've had your third
interaction you build it's like any
relationship
you